and hurled numerous other false
accusations and aspersions
soon afterwards the kremlin announced
that russian troops would enter the
breakaway regions under the guise of
peacekeepers
and russian tanks and armored personnel
carriers have since been spotted the
house
should be in no doubt that the
deployment of these forces in sovereign
ukrainian territory amounts to a renewed
invasion of that country and by denying
ukraine's legitimacy as a state
and presenting its very existence as a
mortal threat to russia putin is
establishing the pretext
for a full-scale offensive
i think honourable members will struggle
to understand
how in the or to contemplate how in the
year 2022
a national leader might calmly and
deliberately plot the destruction
of a peaceful neighbor
and yet the evidence in his of his own
words suggests that is exactly what
president putin is doing
when i said on saturday that he schemed
to subvert and invade ukraine was
already in motion before our eyes
the events of the last 24 hours have
sadly shown this to be true
we must now brace ourselves for the next
possible stages of putin's plan
the violent subversion of areas of
eastern ukraine by russian operatives
and their harlings
followed by a general offensive by the
nearly 200 000 russian troops gathered
on the frontiers at peak readiness to
attack
if the worst happens
then a european nation of 44 million men
women and children would become the
target of a full-scale war
of aggression
waged
without a shred
of justification
for the absurd and even mystical reasons
that putin described last night
unless the situation changes the best
efforts of the united states of this
country france germany and other allies
to avoid conflict
through patient
diplomacy
may be in
vain from the beginning we have tried
our rightmost we've all tried to find a
peaceful way through this crisis on the
11th of february my right honourable
friend the defense secretary and the
chief of the defense staff admiral
radekin
paid the first joint visit to moscow by
the holders of their offices since
churchill who was also defence minister
at the time traveled to russia with
general allen brooke in 1944.
they held over three hours of frank
discussions with the russian defense
minister general shoigu and the chief of
staff general garasimov
demonstrating how seriously we take
russia's security concerns how much
we respect her history
and how hard we are prepared to work
to ensure peaceful coexistence my right
honourable friend the foreign secretary
delivered the same messages when she met
our russian counterpart in moscow on the
10th
of february i've spoken on a number of
occasions to president putin since this
crisis began so does president biden
while president macron and chancellor
schultz have both visited moscow
together we have explored every avenue
and given putin every opportunity
to pursue his aims by negotiation and
diplomacy and i will tell the house we
will not give up
we will continue to seek a diplomatic
solution until the last possible moment
but we have to face
the possibility that none of our
messages has been heeded and that putin
is implacably determined
to go further
in subjugating and tormenting ukraine
and it is because we suspected as much
that the uk and our allies repeatedly
sounded the alarm about a possible new
invasion and we disclosed much of what
we knew about russia's military buildup
britain has done everything possible to
help ukraine to prepare for another
onslaught training 22 000 soldiers
supplying 2 000 anti-tank missiles and
providing 100 million pounds for
economic reform and energy independence
we will now guarantee up to 500 million
dollars of development bank financing
i traveled to kiev to meet president
zolensky on the 1st of february i saw
him again in
munich the weekend i spoke to him again
last night
soon after
president putin's speech
to assure him as i'm sure the whole
house
would would would agree was the right
thing to do i assured him of britain's
unwavering support for ukraine's
ukraine's sovereignty and territorial
integrity
and now the uk and our allies will begin
begin to impose the sanctions on russia
that we have already prepared using the
new and unprecedented powers granted by
this house to sanction russian
individuals and entities of strategic
importance to the kremlin
the uk is sanctioning the following five
russian banks
russia is bank
general bank
promising as bank and the black sea bank
and we are sanctioning three very high
net worth individuals gennady timchenko
boris rottenberg and eagle rottenberg
any assets they hold in the uk
will be frozen the individuals concerned
will be banned from traveling here and
we will prohibit all uk individuals and
entities from having any dealings with
them
this is the first trash
the first barrage of what we are
prepared to do and we hold further
sanctions at readiness to be deployed
alongside the united states and the
european union if the situation
escalates still further
last night our diplomats joined an
emergency meeting of the un security
council and we will raise the situation
in the organization for security and
cooperation in europe
and
let me emphasize what i believe unites
every member of this house with equal
determination the resolve
of the united kingdom
to defend our nato allies is absolute
and immovable
we've already doubled the size of our
deployment
in estonia where the british army leads
nato's battle group and when i met
president levitz of latvia and prime
minister kalas of estonia in munich on
saturday i told them that we would be
willing
to send more british forces to help
protect our allies if nato makes such a
request
we cannot tell what will happen in
the days ahead but mr speaker we should
steal ourselves for a protracted crisis
the united kingdom will meet this
challenge side by side with our allies
determined that we will not allow putin
to drag our continent back into a
hobbesian state of nature where
aggression pays and might is right and
it is precisely because the states are
so high
that putin's venture
in ukraine must fail
must ultimately fail and must be seen
to fail
that will require the perseverance
and the unity and the resolve of the
entire western alliance and
britain the uk will do everything
possible to ensure
that that unity is maintained
and now
our thoughts should turn
to our valiant ukrainian friends
who threaten no one
who ask for nothing
except to live in peace
and freedom
we will keep pace keep faith with them
in the critical days that lie ahead
and whatever happens mr speaker britain
will not waver in our resolve and i
commend this statement to the house
leader of the opposition kirstama
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker
yesterday was a dark day for europe
the russian president denied the right
of a sovereign nation to exist
unilaterally recognizing separatist
movements that he sponsors and who seek
to dismember ukraine
and then under the cover of darkness
sent in troops to enforce his will putin
appears determined to plunge ukraine
into a wider war
we must all stand firm in our support
for ukraine
we support the freedom of her people and
their right to determine their own
future
without the gun of an imperialist held
to their head
there can be no excuses for russia's
actions
there is no justification
for this aggression
a war in ukraine will be bloody
it will cost lives
and history will rightly scorn putin as
the aggressor
putin claims to fear nato expansion
but russia faces no conceivable threat
from allied troops or from ukraine
what he fears
is openness and
he knows
that given a choice
people will not choose to live under the
rule of an erratic and violent
authoritarian
so we must remain united and true to our
values across this house and with our
nato allies
we must show putin that we will not be
divided
i welcome the sanctions introduced today
and the international community's
efforts to unite with a collective
response
however we must be prepared to go
further
i understand the tactic of holding back
sanctions on putin and his cronies
to try to deter an invasion of the rest
of ukraine
but a threshold has already been
breached
a sovereign nation has been invaded in a
war of aggression based on lies and
fabrication
if we do not respond with a full set of
sanctions now
putin will once again take away the
message that the benefits of aggression
outweigh the costs
so we will work with the prime minister
and our international allies
to ensure that more sanctions are
introduced
russia should be excluded from financial
mechanisms like swift
and we should ban trading in russia and
sovereign debt
putin's campaign of misinformation
should be tackled
russia today should be prevented from
broadcasting its propaganda around the
world and we should work with our
european allies to ensure that nordstrom
2 pipeline is cancelled
whatever the sequencing of these
sanctions
this won't be easy
britain must work with our european
allies to handle the disruption in the
supply of energy and raw materials
we must defend ourselves and our allies
against cyber attacks
we must bring together the widest
possible coalition of nations to condemn
this action against a sovereign un
member state
ukrainians are defending their own
country
and democracy in europe
we must stand ready with more military
support for ukraine to defend itself
and we must stand ready to do more to
reassure and reinforce nato allies in
eastern europe
but we must also get our own house in
order
the prime minister said the lesson from
russia's 2014 invasion of donbass is
that you can't just let vladimir putin
get away with it
but until now we have
we have failed to stop the flow of
illicit russian finance into britain
a cottage industry does the bidding of
those linked to putin
and russian money has been allowed to
influence our politics
we have to admit that mistakes have been
made
we have to rectify them
this must be a turning point
an end to oligarch impunity
we need to draw a line on company's
house providing easy cover for shell
companies
we need to ensure our anti-money
laundering laws are enforced
we need to crack down on spies
and we have to make sure money isn't
pouring into uk politics from abroad
[Music]
russian aggression has now torn up the
minks protocol
and the budapest memorial
but even at this late hour we must
pursue diplomatic routes to prevent
further conflict so can the prime
minister tell us what international
diplomatic efforts are going on
and what role the uk will have in that
process
mr speaker we know putin's playbook
he seeks division
we must stay united
he believes the benefits of aggression
outweigh the consequences
so we must take a stand
and he believes the west is too
corrupted to do the right thing
so we must prove him wrong
i believe we can
and i offer the support of the
opposition
in that vital endeavor
thank you mr speaker
prime minister mr speaker can i thank
the right honourable general the leader
of the opposition for the uh the clarity
with which he has just spoken and the uh
support that he has given uh to uh the
uk's strategy in dealing with this
crisis in europe and i think uh if if i
may say so that uh that will be noted
and the change in the approach taken by
the oppositionism is i think massively
uh over the last couple of years mr
speaker
is massively
massively massively beneficial the
change over the last couple of years mr
speaker which i think i think that a
fair-minded person uh would acknowledge
and he's raised some he's raised some
important questions
and uh they relate to the
uh to the
the ways in which we clamped down on uh
russian money in in the uk and indeed uh
throughout throughout the west and this
country was the first to publish a
register of beneficial ownership this
country has led the way in cracking down
on uh the the on wealth that is
unexplained and we are bringing forward
an economic crime bill uh to take to
take forward further measures mr
speaking and i think it is i think i
should understand it is absolutely vital
that we hold in reserve uh further
powerful sanctions as i think the right
honourable gentleman uh acknowledged uh
in in view of what president putin may
do next and we want to stop russian
companies from being able uh to raise
funds uh in sterling or indeed in
dollars uh mr speaker we want to stop
them raising funds on uk markets and we
want to strip away the veil uh that
conceals the ownership of property in
this country and indeed throughout the
west and we will work with our friends
and partners around the world to achieve
that and the sanctions we're
implementing today are are very tough uh
promzia's bank uh is one is a top ten uh
russian bank and it services 70
of state contracts signed by the russian
ministry of defence but the measures
that we have uh prepared are much much
tougher still and we will have
absolutely no hesitation in in
implementing them and mr speaker we will
uh we will get on uh with the business
of uh of diplomacy and he's absolutely
right to draw attention to uh the
importance of diplomacy now in spite of
everything that is happening in uh on
the borders of ukraine and now in
donbass uh the there is a g7 uh meeting
straight after this uh statement mr
speaker we will be holding meetings uh
in nato in the uh in the p5 and uh in
every forum where it is uh it is
relevant and possible to bring
president putin to understand the
gravity of what of what he is doing the
uk will continue
to
offer support to our ukrainian friends
and i do think it has been right for us
to be out in front in offering uh
military assistance defensive military
assistance uh to the ukrainians i think
that has been the right thing to do i
spoke last night uh to president uh
zolensky who made further requests and
we will uh consider them we're doing
everything we can to offer uh offer
support in the time uh that we have and
and we will do that but i i just think
it is worth and i i i'm glad that the
right honourable gentleman seemed to
support that as well uh it is absolutely
vital in the
at this critical moment that president
putin understands that what he is doing
is going to be a disaster for russia
and it is clear it is clear from the
response of the world to what he has
done already in donbass that he is going
to end up with a russia that is poorer
as a result of the sanctions that the
world uh will implement a russia that is
more isolated a russia that has pariah
status uh mr speaker no chance of
holding uh football tournaments in a
russia that invades uh sovereign
countries uh mr speaker and a russia
that is engaged in a bloody and
debilitating conflict with a fellow
country what an appalling what an
appalling result for president putin mr
speaker i hope that he steps back from
the brink and does not conduct a full
invasion but in the meantime mr speaker
we must implement the tough package uh
that we put forward and we will continue
to offer the ukrainian people all the
support that we can
theresa may
thank you mr speaker can i welcome my
right honorable friend statement and
also welcome the uk's unwavering support
for ukrainian sovereignty at this
gravest of times which shows we can
never take our eyes off russia
but does my right honourable friend
share my concern that while the focus
today is rightly on protecting ukrainian
independence and territorial integrity
what lies behind this is a wider
worldwide trend of authoritarian states
trying to impose their way of thinking
on others
and that the battle in which we must now
engage
is nothing more nor less than the
defense of democracy itself
my right normal friend is is entirely
right and that is what is at stake and
uh what happens in uh ukraine what is
happening in ukraine now is being
watched around the world and the echoes
will be heard uh in taiwan uh in east
asia and throughout the world
we don't come to the leader of the snp
in blackfoot
thank you mr speaker can i thank the
prime minister for advanced site of his
statement and to the national security
adviser who has briefed opposition
leaders
mr speaker
this is a dark day for the people of
ukraine and for people right across our
european continent europe stands
on the brink of war
as a consequence of russian aggression
it is a day that communities across
scotland right across these islands and
indeed across europe
desperately hoped would never come to
pass
but although that sense of darkness
defines today
how we now collectively respond will
define the days to come
this chamber
especially during recent months
has seen fierce debate and disagreements
but today
i think it's important to say
in the face of russian aggression
against ukraine
that in this house
that we all stand together
stand together
and stand with our partners
across europe and indeed across the
globe
but more importantly mr speaker
we stand with the ukrainian people
who are now under assault
a european country
an ally is under attack
we should be very clear about what is
now happening this is an illegal russian
occupation of ukraine just as it was in
crimea
russia has effectively annexed another
two ukrainian regions in a blatant
breach of international law this
effectively ends the minsk process
it is a further violation
of the sovereignty and territorial
integrity of ukraine
no one
should even repeat the russian lie that
this is about peacekeeping
mr speaker this is warmongering plain
and simple
president putin
must hear the call from here and
elsewhere to draw back
before any further escalation can take
place
mr speaker
i and my party welcome the sanctions
that are now being brought forward
but it's deeply regrettable that the
delay has allowed many russian
individuals to shift dirty assets and
money in the last number of weeks but
can i ask the prime minister
specifically if the russian state and
individuals will immediately be
suspended from the swift payment system
and just as economic sanctions against
russia are welcome
ukraine needs immediate economic and
indeed humanitarian support if required
when will economic and humanitarian
support be enacted and what will it
entail
can the prime minister also confirm
that there will be exemptions for
partners of uk citizens residing in the
ukraine
to come to the united kingdom they need
that certainty and they need it today
in the days ahead we can no doubt expect
a barrage of disinformation from the
russian media and its proxies
so can the prime minister update on how
the united kingdom government intends to
combat that threat
this is also the moment to end the
complacency in implementing the security
committee's russia report will the prime
minister now commit its full
implementation and update the house
accordingly
can i also ask the prime minister
that after the u.n security council
meeting last night the brief meeting
when it will next meet
and what coordination is happening
across all international organizations
to force president putin to step back
from the brink before it is too late
finally
let president putin hear loudly and
clearly that he must now desist from
this act of war this attack on a
sovereign nation
let us all demonstrate that we stand
with the people of ukraine
mr speaker can i wholeheartedly thank
the right honourable gentleman for the
the terms in which he has just spoken
that the unity and the resolve that he
has uh that he has just shown in in
common with the right roman general the
leader of the opposition i i think uh
the spirit that this house is showing
today is is absolutely invaluable and
he's right to raise questions about uh
the speed in which we've been able to uh
to sanction various individuals we did
bring forward the magnitsky sanctions as
he knows and uh he was important in that
uh in that last year uh we are bringing
forward the registered registry of a
beneficial uh ownership faster than any
other uh any other country stripping
away the veil on on on uh russian uh
dirty money he asked about uh about
support for ukraine as i mentioned to
the house uh we've given 100 a million
pounds worth of support uh particularly
for ukraine's uh uh energy uh
energy crisis and also uh for other
economic needs plus the further 500
million uh dollars that i uh that i
announced uh just now and mr speaker the
the diplomatic effort uh is now
intensifying he asks about uh the forums
in which they're taking place the there
is there are more meetings uh in the u.n
but ultimately as as he rightly says
this is up to vladimir putin he and he
alone
can decide uh whether or not to halt uh
what seems to be an absolutely
irresistible uh march towards tragedy
it's down to him it's it's in his head
[Applause]
can i just say i'm expecting to run this
to around 2 o'clock so 12 each other
short questions and certainly piffy
answers would certainly be helpful job
too
thank you mr speaker may i welcome my
right-hand friend's statement today and
indeed the actions of he and his
government over these recent weeks i may
i pay particular tribute to the defense
secretary whose unfailing efforts in
preparing not just the people of ukraine
but our allies in nato for this
aggression has been exemplary
may ask as we are talking about
sanctions today and rightly so
whether my honorable friend right on a
friend will also commit to a foreign
agents registration act we have seen the
action of the insidious work of the
united front for china and indeed of
different outfits for russia to
undermine our democracy and threaten our
way of life would he please bring in
that act and while he is doing it would
he finance
much more the russian service of the bbc
so that the russian people can hear the
truth and not the lies that are being
spread by their own government
i i thank you very much i think it's i
think the russian service of the of the
bbc has done uh an an invaluable job and
uh i i i think it's very very important
that it should continue to be uh to be
financed i'll look at the the the
details of the of their package on his
proposal for a foreign agent uh
registration law we are indeed uh
considering what more we can do uh to
counter threats uh to this country uh
from within
day margaret hodge thank you mr speaker
according to uh expert legal advice i've
seen there are serious flaws in the new
sanctions regime
it may not affect oligarchs close to
putin who do not hold an official
position in a company or own less than
50 percent of shares it's too narrow in
defining the individuals it covers
unlike unlike u.s legislation it's
limited in how we can sanction russian
government officials and the definition
of government of russia excludes the
legislative branch like the jeweler
that means that kleptocrats who have
stolen from the russian people and
support putin would not be caught
of navalny's list of 35 only 13 would be
caught abramovic usmanov timchenko or
jerry pascal would escape
will the prime minister look again at
the sanctions regime so that in the
words of the foreign secretary nothing
is off the table
uh i thank her very much and i i think
that uh uh i understand her concern but
i i believe that she's an error in what
she says because we cannot we can
certainly target uh members of the of
the duma and brahmavich who's already uh
facing sanctions and in the
announcements that i've made today uh
gennady tim chenko at whom she just
referred is specifically targeted uh
he's on the list uh she's just mentioned
him he's on the list uh as is uh uh
boris rottenberg and igor rottenberg and
we these are uh people who are very
close to the putin regime but as i said
to the house they are just part of the
first barrage
figure could i welcome the government's
efforts today but russians actions move
us into a new and more dangerous uh
phase of this crisis and requires us to
adapt a more robust long-term approach
to defending european security outside
of nato's borders sanctions alone will
not be enough indeed untargeted
sanctions may play into putin's plan to
pivot russia ever closer to china so
would the prime minister agree nato must
not be benched it was created to uphold
european security and we must now
consider how we utilize our formidable
hard power deterrence in responding to
ukraine's calls for further help not
excluding the formation of potential
no-fly zone
i i i thank the right gentleman very
much and he's absolutely right to place
the emphasis that he does on nato and
nato has proved its value over the last
70 years it is the preeminent most
successful uh alliance in history it is
a defensive alliance and uh we are
reinforcing it now on the eastern uh all
across the eastern perimeter uh what
nato is not doing and no nato is current
no nato country is currently considering
sending combat troops uh to ukraine and
he will understand uh the reasons for
that but that does not preclude uh
support by nato countries for ukraine
and uh including military support mr
speaker david thank you mr speaker
it's time to start treating russia like
the rogue state it is
and i strongly welcome the prime
minister's statement on this darkest of
moments
and i recognize the leaders opposition
for his strong cross-party support
and in that cross-party spirit can i
urge the prime minister to go further
today
and commit to the following
first freeze and begin seizing the
assets of every single one of putin's
cronies in the uk
and then expel these oligarchs from our
country as part of a much stronger
sanctions regime
second mr speaker recognize the
existential threat posed by putin to our
nato allies
by immediately canceling cancelling his
own decision his misguided decision to
cut our armed forces by 10 000 troops
and third no longer tolerate
international sporting or cultural
events hosted in russia so can i can i
confirm what i think he implied in an
answer to a previous question that he
will push for this year's champions
league final to be moved from st
petersburg
mr speaker mr putin president putin has
made a terrible decision
will the prime minister make sure he
pays a terrible price yeah yeah
yes mr speaker and again i'm grateful to
him uh and his party for uh for their
support and for the position uh that uh
we're taking we are indeed cracking down
on uh ill-gotten gains in london and exp
and uh on and on the cronies of vladimir
putin as i've just uh detailed and there
is more to come on his point about
uh defense uh spending uh i think he
should acknowledge that the uh recent uh
increase was the biggest uh biggest
since the uh the end of the of the cold
war and mr speaker on his point about uh
sporting events as i said earlier on i
think it inconceivable that major
international uh football uh tournaments
uh can take place uh in uh in uh in
russia after as i say the invasion of a
sovereign country so julie lewis
speaker does my right honourable friend
accept that too many nato governments
and political parties have accepted
energy dependence on putin
and financial dependence on dodgy
donations from russian oligarchs
given that we spent between four and a
half and five percent of gdp on defense
throughout the 1980s until the end of
the cold war will he now accept three
percent of gdp on defense as a suitable
future benchmark
uh the right on general it's completely
right to say that we have failed to wean
ourselves off dependence on russian
hydrocarbons uh since 2014. i think
that's been a tragic mistake uh by uh by
european countries that the in the uk
we're in the fortune position of only
having three percent of our gas coming
from russia but other european countries
have learned that they have much more to
do by the way i salute uh the decision
of the german chancellor olaf schultz uh
to to cancel nordstrom 2 i think it's a
brave step by olaf and the right and the
right thing to do on on his point about
defense spending actually we're up at
2.4 percent now uh of gdp uh i think one
of the very highest in nato and we are
the second biggest contributor second
biggest military power in nato already
bernie chairman
mr speaker did i say to the prime
minister that uh
america is key on all this uh it's the
largest economy it's the largest forces
in nato
we were honored by having nancy pelosi
in this chamber yesterday
she's very close to president
of the united states did he have a
chance to talk to her because it isn't
good enough for us cross party wonderful
unity in this house but we need the
united states to be firm the leadership
with us
i i i thank him very much and i didn't i
did have a chance to talk to nancy uh
and uh pelosi and her uh her bipartisan
delegation and i must say uh mr speaker
that the the sentiments that have been
expressed by members of this house
already uh today were very much shared
uh by that uh delegation of congressmen
and women dr liam fox
mr speaker can i welcome my right on
defense statements and say that i think
the uk government has behaved with
integrity and honor throughout this
crisis and i echo his welcoming of
chancellor schultz's brave decision
today to freeze nordstrom 2.
but can i say to my right honourable
friend sanctions can only achieve so
much when dealing with an undemocratic
state and someone like putin
what we're witnessing is the real-time
cannibalization of a european democratic
state
bite by bite and ultimately we will have
to ensure that either ukraine is given
the means to defend itself from future
aggression or give some sort of security
guarantee or we will find russian troops
on the borders of poland slovakia
romania and hungary which would be an
absolute failure of western policy yeah
yeah
uh my my right-hand
a friend has uh
has written and spoken powerfully about
this subject recently and he's he's
completely right in the sense that we
will have to uh bed in we will have to
dig in for the long term uh to support
ukraine in every way that we can
economically diplomatically by the
provision of of military uh support in
the way that we uh are already mr
speaker but it will take it will take
time but i think there is let me get
back to the point i made in uh in my
opening statement
it is vital that president putin should
fail
and i believe that he will fail because
i believe that the giant facts are
against him he is taking on a ukrainian
national feeling and in the end he will
not succeed and we will help uh the
ukrainians to succeed so tony lloyd
thank you thank you mr speaker the the
the promise will know that part of the
calculation of the kremlin and president
putin is that the west will lose
interest
in as we have done unfortunately in the
past can he make it one of his key tasks
to ensure that our allies are there for
the long run because we've got to be
there until this is brought to a proper
conclusion
i thank him very much and i think he's
completely right and the the biggest
threat is apathy and and indifference
and that's why i think uh what uh my
right old friend uh the member for
maidenhead had to say was so important
this is not just about ukraine this is
about democracy and this is about uh the
security of many other european
countries indeed countries around the
world that's what's at stake here today
and duncan smith speaker can i commend
my right-able friend and his colleagues
for their very stalwart actions so far
the fact is that uh mr lavrov today said
and i quote ukraine does not have a
right to sovereignty so the ambition and
the scale of that ambition is surely
completely clear to anybody that doubts
it and so i asked my writable friend
should it not be now and i commend what
he's done so far but should it not be
that we need to hit them if we're going
to hit them with sanctions hard and hit
them now they need to feel the pain of
the first part of this decision the
second thing is
what is the ultimatum to them now if
they move further are we going to take
further action and i simply say right
now we are facing the growth of the axis
of totalitarian states china will watch
this and look at taiwan
how we behave now and what we do
as an alliance will dictate what happens
in the far east
mr speaker we are hitting them hard now
and we will hit them harder in the
future with every with every uh day that
goes by in which they violate the
sovereignty and integrity of ukraine we
will continue to punish russia and in
the end i don't believe that president
putin has thought this through and i i
do think that he will fail
chris brown thank you mr speaker putin
as i've been saying for many years is a
bloodthirsty liar
and when his ambassador came to the
house a couple of weeks ago to talk to
the all-party group on russia
uh he said it was absolutely
preposterous that anybody could possibly
suggest that any russian troops would be
going in to ukraine that was a lie then
not an inadvertent lie a deliberate lie
but my anxiety is that we're not going
anywhere near far enough today
in 2014 we were spineless in the end we
didn't show enough resolve across the
west or in the uk we didn't close down
the dirty money
process coming into the uk
i don't think abramovic has been
sanctioned incidentally just to correct
the prime minister i don't think he's
been sanctioned yet at all
so i think it's really important
precisely what the former leader of the
conservative party just said
everybody in this house will work
closely with the government to deliver
far more effective and secure
um sanctions if the prime minister asks
but they have to be now we have to close
the dirty much russian money down
mr speaker this country this government
is already uh implementing uh a as a
draconian package of of sanctions and
and we will uh go further we're bringing
forward the uh the economic crime bill
the register of beneficial uh interests
in addition mr speaker
to all the things that uh that i've
announced uh today we will be bringing
forward further measures uh to hit
russian individuals and russian
companies as i said a strategic
importance to uh to russia and uh
stopping russia from russian companies
from raising money on london markets
stopping them even trading in pounds and
dollars these will bite these will hurt
and these will make a huge difference
but but uh mr speaker i think with the
house also needs to understand that
president putin's failure will not just
be caused by sanctions implemented by us
by our friends uh his failure will
result from the determination of the
ukrainians to resist and in that we will
support them
i welcome these sanctions in the
government's significant efforts to
expose false flag operations but ruble
by ruble we must rid our nation of
putin's dirty money because of his acts
overnight and those lives already lost i
urge my right on a friend to backlist
all russian banks but to ban this city
and law and accountancy firms from
servicing all russian state firms and to
work with turkey to deny the russian
navy access to the bosphorus and ensure
we have an atrocity prevention strategy
in place for when the para militaries go
in alongside the peacekeepers
uh i thank you very much and uh that is
exactly why the uk has been out in front
of our of our european friends in uh
dealing with russian dirty money and and
in uh implementing the toughest uh
possible package of sanctions that i
told the house uh we will go further
thank you very much mr speaker these are
perilous times for our friends in
ukraine a democracy within our continent
and short of sending british troops
there we must provide them with every
possible support i'm glad that the prime
minister is talking tough and taking a
strong stand against continued russian
aggression and imperialism but when will
he himself
stop playing tennis with russian
oligarchs in exchange for money for the
conservative party
and instead of talking about sanctions
abroad when will he finally help to
clean up things closer to home including
fully implementing the recommendations
of the russia report
so uh mr speaker the the government as i
said is way out in front of uh of our
other european friends and partners in
what we're doing uh to implement
sanctions uh on on russian entities and
that's the right thing i think that's
where the house is uh today and and we
will we will continue to do that and uh
yes mr speaker it is absolutely vital
that nobody should uh contribute to a
political party in this country unless
they're a uk national that is what the
uh this that and that is for something
that this government has what this
that's what this government uh insists
upon but what i don't think we should
see mr speaker if i may just
respectfully say i might i've just been
listening to some of the contributions
uh this morning we should not allow uh
our uh our indignation our rage what is
happening in uh in ukraine to spill over
into casual russophobia uh mr speaker i
don't want to see us discriminating
against russians as a people uh or
simply on the basis of their nationality
william cash
mr speaker may i commend my right
honourable friend for his prescience and
resolve on ukraine
and also that of the defense secretary
can it confirm that escalating economic
sanctions against russia
and fully effective defensive support
for ukraine can never be allowed to fail
given that russia and president putin's
aggression affects all its european
neighbors and has an ever increasing
global reach including even in places
like africa yeah
the right honourable general my right
friend is completely right uh the the
threat is not just to uh europe the
threat from uh a uh an aggressive and
expansionist
uh russian agenda is is everybody
including in africa from the wagner
group uh mr speaker
and it is up to the uk now uh to push
back and that's what we're going to do
dave angela reid
thank you very much mr speaker would the
prime minister tell the house now uh
whether the
sanctions that he has announced will
actually put into effect
the
intelligence and securities committee's
russia report
and whether he has full confidence that
this will close down
the so-called london
laundromat
which is
uh laundering dirty russian money
straight through the city
as she would have understood from what
i've said earlier on what we're
proposing to do will go further uh than
that than that report uh we we were
cracking down today on on russian banks
on russian individuals but what we are
proposing to do is to stop russian
companies even from raising money uh in
london and to stop them trading uh in
sterling and that was not recommended by
the report she uh she mentions but that
will do real real economic uh
it is necessary to do it johnny mercer
thank you very much uh mr speaker and i
welcome the prime minister's statement
today and sanctions against russia but
would you agree with me that we can't
continue to consistently re-learn the
lessons of the past when it comes to
drawing a line and being willing to hold
that line militarily if so
and whilst he has all he has increased
defense spending beyond what it has been
for many years and i congratulate him
for that the argument has always been
that that must be tailored to meet the
threat and as the german chancellor has
mentioned this morning that threat is
changing and will he commit to keep an
eye on that defence spending to make
sure that if we are asked we can hold a
line and we can lead nato in the way
that i know he wants to i i thank him
very much and he's absolutely right to
draw attention to defense spending and
uh it's great that uh the german
chancellor also now sees the importance
of this for a long time uh he and i i'm
sure have been uh campaigning for
germany to shoulder uh more of the
defense uh burden of the cost of defense
uh in uh in in europe and that's a
that's a good thing uh
we've seen massive increases in our
defense spending but we all want to make
sure that it is targeted on things like
tackling uh cyber uh disinformation uh
all the modern forms of warfare in which
putin also specialises sure jose mr
speaker can i welcome the sanctions
announced today on the five banks and
the three named individuals
however the prime minister will be well
aware
there are many many oligarchs who would
at face value have huge wealth and huge
assets
in their own names
but that wealth and those assets are
absolutely in the gift of the russian
state and at the beck and call of the
russian state so can i confirm that the
sanctions we will be discussing and
agreeing later today
do intend to make sure those trusted
custodians of russian state money
are able to be sanctioned in the way the
three individuals named today are
being uh
yes mr speaker we will be able to
sanction uh oligarchs associates of uh
of president putin and companies of
strategic importance to the kremlin good
luck
thank you mr speaker i really welcome
the prime minister's statement today and
in particular the level of cross-house
agreement that there is that we must
stand up to russian aggression i also
welcome chancellor schultz deciding to
suspend nordstrom 2. it always was an
incredibly risky project allowing great
exposure to russian gas so can my right
honourable friend assure the house that
he is already considering what more can
be done to protect our allies and
friends in eastern europe from the
inevitable consequences of the risky
position we find ourselves in in the
dead of winter with so much dependence
on russian gas
i i thank her very much and i think the
answer is that we need to work together
uh to wean ourselves off uh to end the
dependency on on russian gas the house
knows that all the things we're doing to
support our eastern european allies
military but we also need to share uh
technology particularly in renewables to
uh to allow them to find a different
future
hello ben
mr speaker whether the sanctions that
the prime minister has just announced
will hit russia hard as he said this
morning only time will tell but the
prime minister also said something else
he said there's a lot more that we're
going to do in the event of an invasion
now the prime minister's just told the
house that he regards what happened
overnight as a renewed invasion
of ukraine
and if that is the government's view
then why is he waiting before imposing
full sanctions on russia
now
a couple of points
mr speaker the house would have hurt me
on this several times and i've i'd be
very clear that uh what we wanted to do
was uh to have the biggest possible
package of sanctions ready to go in the
event of a russian tow cap crossing into
more sovereign uh ukrainian territory uh
what we but but what we will also do is
make sure uh make sure that the uh the
waves of sanctions that we implement are
done in concert with our allies and
that's what we're doing
thank you thank you mr speaker can i
ask my right honourable friend to
reflect while thanking him for his
statement
that
president putin has already achieved so
much of what he set out to achieve
and that he
uh may have no intention of launching a
full-scale invasion of the ukraine but
he has already committed the crimes that
deserve the most severest punishment
from the free world
and what are we going to do to continue
to strengthen nato to unify nato which
is exactly of course what he didn't want
his policy to achieve
he and what he's you my own friend is
completely right what he succeeded in
doing is uh greatly to unify nato and to
produce a a much bigger commitment not
just by the uk but by other major
european powers to the uh reinforcement
of nato's uh eastern frontier uh the
french are uh doubling down in romania
we're doubling down in uh estonia uh
he's going to get much more nato not
less
[Applause]
to george
thank you mr speaker
for over a decade
uh russia have been mounting cyber
attacks
on our critical national infrastructure
and commercial interests for over a
decade
and there were no consequences
for over a decade
russia
has been
swirling dirty money around the city of
london
and there were no consequences
in order for vladimir putin to
understand
that he has now
gone too far
he needs to be certain
that if sanctions and diplomatic means
don't succeed
then there will be consequences can the
right honourable gentleman agree with me
that those consequences need to be still
on the table
and
vladimir putin under needs to understand
that they will be used
completely right that we need to uh make
it absolutely clear to to russia that as
a result of this venture this uh
ill-conceived and disastrous venture in
uh in ukraine his country will end up as
i said uh poorer uh more encircled by
nate uh by nato and engaged in a a a
disastrous conflict uh with uh with
fellow slavs and a pariah state a pariah
that is what president putin is willing
on his people
pariah state that's what they'll become
david morris
mr speaker mr speaker there's more at
stake here than just sanctions we have
various international protocols that
have been drafted over literally decades
going back to the last war where does
this incursion into the ukraine actually
leave us with these protocols and how
can we enforce
um
any further measures against any
breaches of these protocols
i thank him he's completely right
because this uh this this tears up the
uh the 1994 budapest memorandum it makes
an absolute nonsense of the whole minsk
uh process the agreement of of 2014
that's uh ripped up uh two uh
international law has been mocked by
what uh president putin uh has done and
uh that is what is at stake it is it is
democracy in the rule of law across the
world there's several roberts
putin last night confirmed that he is a
ruthless imperialist poised to destroy
ukraine's sovereignty and
self-determination and i too i'm
grateful for the briefing for the
national security advisor
we must now hit putin where it hurts as
of this morning bp's website proudly
proclaims that it is one of the biggest
foreign investors in russia owning
nearly 20 of russia's oil giant rosneft
rosneft also has a secondary holding in
london
will the prime minister commit to
imposing legally mandated divestment by
uk firms in russia and if not now when
mr speaker i i think we do have to
recognize that the uh the lesson of 2014
is we have to move away from the
dependence on russian hydrocarbons and
and the government will be pursuing
policies to that end
richard drax
speaker can i congratulate my ottoman
friend and the defense secretary for the
brilliant work they've done in this very
very difficult time
mr putin is a bully and bullies only
stand up or recognize one thing that is
military force
if we are to fight for the freedom that
we claim to hold so dear we've got to
pay to defend it
will my rival friend go back to the eu
and nato in particular and say we've got
to raise our spending budgets to at
least three percent have more planes
more ships more men to deter not wage
war to deter and prevent one from
happening
uh
i thank you very much he's completely
right and uh i can tell him that the
british government is continually
exhorting our uh our european friends to
exceed the uh the two percent threshold
it'd be a great thing if we could get uh
someone up to two percent then never
mind uh three percent mr speaker
thank the prime minister for his
statement today and welcome the
sanctions against the three individuals
that he's named uh but the
regulations which you referred to which
will be discussed later on today will
only be effective if there's a political
will to actually implement them
under part four of the regulations it
defines the individual as an influence
involved in obtaining benefit
from or supporting government of the
government of russia the writing member
for dundee east uh
raised the issue around and it's a fact
that oligarchs uh are operating in this
country with property
are uh supporting the
the russian government both financially
and politically so will we bring uh
sanctions against those individuals he
named abramovic he's just one of many
uh
yes mr speaker what we will be uh doing
is targeting any uh individual or
company of of strategic importance uh to
russia
sharon
thank you mr speaker i warmly welcome my
right honourable friends statement and i
commend the west for seeing through the
orwellian doublespeak of putin and his
cronies i
agree with my right honourable friend
with regard to a staged approach to
sanctions but now that we have an
incursion into donetsk and luhansk is
not the next stage to demand an
immediate withdrawal by russia from
those regions
and if not further sanctions must follow
as a direct consequence
yes of course uh and he the myra friend
is completely right that the there
should be an immediate uh withdrawal by
uh by russia and uh uh i i wish i could
be confident that that will happen well
i'm afraid all the omens are pointing in
the opposite direction and i think that
uh the house will need to consider a a
much bigger package of sanctions and
further measures of all kinds i'll deal
with them
thank you mr speaker the polish
government has said that it must be
prepared to accept up to one million
refugees displaced by conflict or fling
for fear of persecution yet last week
when asked about accepting ukrainian
refugees our foreign secretary said and
i quote we can't make any commitments
about any refugees at this stage
amid conflict we must always put direct
support for people first so will the
government today commit to accepting all
ukrainian refugees who wish to come to
the uk
and also those persecuted in russia for
their resistance to war and putin's
regime
i thank you very much
what we're doing is getting helping the
countries that are
directly uh vulnerable to
an exodus of refugees from uh from
ukraine we put another thousand troops
on on standby and this country will
continue to do what it has always uh
done and uh receive those who are
fleeing in fear of persecution that's
what we will do
i strongly support the robust approach
taken by my right honourable friend
which indeed he took us foreign
secretary
but putin will have predicted and
discounted western sanctions long ago so
does he agree that if we are not to be
behind in the diplomatic chess game we
need to do some things that he is not
expecting firstly a sustained increase
in western defense capability and spend
and secondly a sustained reduction in
the ability of the russian state to
finance its own armed forces with
economic and financial sanctions that
don't last
just until the next government decides
to have a reset but if necessary for as
long as this dangerous man remains
president of russia yeah yeah yeah
we've seen a 10 increase in uh defense
spending in this in this country we will
sustain uh that increase in in defense
spending and he's absolutely right about
the financing of putin's armed forces
and the tragedy is that they've been
financed from the proceeds of the sale
of russian oil and gas to western
european nations and that is what has
got to end
caroline lucas
thank you very much mr speaker it is
vital to stand in solidarity with
ukraine in the face of outrageous
russian aggression with robust
far-reaching sanctions and by closing
down london's money laundering machine
now frankly sanctions on five banks and
three oligarchs doesn't go anywhere near
enough
but with that we must also recognize the
extent of russian meddling in our own
politics so will the prime minister stop
studiously ignoring the russia report
from the intelligence and security
committee which found credible evidence
of a interfere with the uk's election
process
comprehensive investigation
mr speaker we're going further than the
russia report in uh implementing uh
sanctions against uh against russia uh
and uh of course we would do anything uh
to root out any foreign uh influence in
any uh uk election but i'm not aware of
that
speaker and i welcome the statement made
by the prime minister
tough sanctions require tough compliance
in a statement the prime minister
mentioned that uk individuals and
entities
should not have any dealings with the
banks and
russian individuals that he mentioned
would he therefore
given assurance to this house that any
uk individuals
or institutions that do
have dealings with these banks and
individuals for them they will be the
severest of penalties
yes indeed uh mr speaker those who uh
bet uh sanctioned people help them to
evade uh money laundering uh anti-money
laundering uh provisions uh help them to
conceal uh a beneficial uh interests uh
will of course uh be breaking the law
themselves
the three oligarchs his sanction today
have been sanctioned by the united
states for four years
we need to do better than that prime
minister
so will he re-examine the operation of
unexplained wealth orders not to single
one of which has been issued since he
became prime minister and when he
published the list of all of those
russians who've obtained fast-track
visas for the residency he referred to
earlier by giving cash to the uk
exchequer
[Applause]
mr speaker the national crime agency is
pursuing uh
many investigations against uh people
for uh unexplained uh on unexplained
wealth orders uh but on uh on on his a
point about visas uh we're stopping tier
one uh visas from russia
much uh mr speaker can i just press the
prime minister little on the answer he
gave to the right honourable member for
leeds central i welcome his statement
and its robust
um approach and the fact that he's
confirmed
that what president putin has done does
amount to an invasion of ukraine with
the necessary measures that follow but
an answer to the right honourable
gentleman the prime minister seemed to
suggest that
if if what vladimir putin's done was
limited to these
alleged breakaway republics
that was a line
and he had to do something else to
trigger further sanctions can i just ask
the prime minister to confirm that what
he's already done means that we will be
following up with further and stronger
measures even if president putin does no
more
i i think it's inevitable given what is
uh happening in uh ukraine and on the
borders of ukraine that we will be
coming forward uh with the uh a much
bigger package of
sanctions mr speaker uh what what you
have today is an opening uh barrage that
we're doing uh in uh in uh common uh
with our friends and allies good job
the prime minister's focus rightly will
be on the here and now but when he finds
a moment to reflect both on the recent
failures in afghanistan but also it
being overwhelmingly clear that russia
was is and will continue to be the
greatest threat to peace and security in
europe i wonder whether he might
conclude that the indo-pacific tilt as
outlined in the integrated review will
need to be reassessed
the the the intake actually i'm glad
that he's brought up the integrated
review because he you will see that uh
very early on in the integrated review
we say clearly
that the
euro atlantic theater is our number one
uh issue of concern
john berlin
mr speaker i welcome the statement and
commend the prime minister and his
government on its robust approach but i
hope he takes away from this exchange
today
the strong cross party support for
tougher sanctions now because that is
what is needed
i suggest to the prime minister that the
russian invasion of ukraine
and the fact that we've now entered a
new era when it comes to the battle of
for democracy globally
will he now consider a substantial and
sustained increase in defense spending
well above the 2.4 percent that is
required to ensure stability in and
peace in our time because george or if
indeed there is room for george or in
the future
will be more effective with stronger
armed forces
i i'm grateful tim and uh
my honourable friend uh i'm also proud
of the substantial very substantial
uplift in our uh defence spending that
we've been able to uh provide and with
the strongest uh uh the fastest growing
economy uh in europe as a result of the
measures that this uh in the g7 i should
say is a result of measures this
government has has taken i'm confident
that we're going to be able to continue
to give our armed forces the investment
they need
champion
thank you mr speaker ukraine has been
experienced conflict since 2014 creating
a crisis of 2.9 million people in need
can the prime minister please confirm
that the uk stands ready to work with
the government of the ukraine and
international partners in providing
humanitarian assistance should the
conflict exacerbate
yes of course
no problem
john howell
thank you mr speaker can i welcome my
right honourable friend statement i am
calling today for the suspension of
russia from the council of europe it
cannot be right it cannot be right for a
country to have violated the human
rights of another member of the council
of europe so profoundly will he support
my actions
can i thank my honourable friend for
everything he does in the council of
europe for the robust positions uh that
he takes it in that body and i i
wholeheartedly support what he just said
i'm malcolm
i'm grateful mr uh i'm grateful mr
speaker the russian disinformation
networks including rt the leader of the
opposition is right and his call on that
license mr speaker but those
disinformation networks are critical to
not just trying to justify russia's
aggression internationally but
maintaining that aggression as well for
how much longer will we continue in this
country to pretend that outfits like rt
are some kind of benign equivalent to
the world service or france 24 they're
not it's time they went yeah yeah
look i i mr speaker i think he's uh his
point will be widely uh shared uh not
perhaps by everybody on the opposition
benches uh but there is we have an
independent regulator of the uh of the
media we don't live in a country uh
where politicians can close down uh
media uh outlets uh it is up to offcom
to rule
in little ranger mr speaker prime
minister is well aware and i'm following
my honourable friend just now that i'm
the group leader in the council of
europe we have ukrainians in our group
prime minister who are now under threat
their families are under threat they are
going to be on the list that the un the
u.s has now given
to their dice intelligence on what
they're getting what's going to happen
to them prime minister we must stand by
these democrats they are good people
i've worked with them for now 10 years i
would have nothing but praise for them
prime minister would you not agree that
the council of europe and other
organizations like this need to stand up
for democracy and stand up for democrats
yes i i thank you and i thank him for
everything he's doing in the council of
europe and we should stand by democratic
ukrainian politicians we all know them
we've all we've all met them all they
want to do is live in uh in peace and
freedom and we should work together uh
to ensure that they can listen mcgovern
thank you mr speaker many syrians will
know that the continuation of putin's
aggression was not only predictable it
was predicted in this house on both
sides of this house
so does the prime minister agree that as
was true in relation to syria the only
response to aggression
is coordinated international resolve
matched by every possible action at home
including each of those
as explained by the leader of the
opposition
uh
mr speaker i think that
the lesson from syria is that uh you
cannot will uh the end of a regime
without being willing to will the means
and uh that is what uh this government
is uh prepared to do and if that is what
the uh if that is what the leader of the
opposition is now committing labour to
then so much better
mark pritchard
speaker
ukraine is not nato's border yet it is
not the eu's border yet
but it is democracy's border today
and this house
as you'll know mr speaker having met the
president some months ago here stands in
full solidarity with our
counterparts in the radha and the people
of ukraine including the people of
donetsk
and luhansk
the prime minister mentioned
nato members
can ask him what more reassurance
and practical support we can give to
nato members
like poland and the baltic states
who today are just a little bit more
fearful
uh he's quite right and he's quite right
to draw attention to the the baltic
states and poland as he knows in poland
uh we've increased our support with
another 350 marines from four five uh
commando uh and in the uh in the bolt in
estonia we've doubled uh our presence in
tapa
to uh to 2000 and we will continue to
keep all the uh all the and we're doing
more in the uh in the high north as well
as in as in romania and elsewhere and
and we will continue to keep all these
uh projects under constant uh constant
review but we in other european
countries are stiffening the eastern
frontier of nato
very much mr speaker
five banks
three of putin's cronies but two of
which have already been sanctioned by
the u.s this isn't us working in concert
this is us already behind yeah i hear
what the prime minister has said about
more sanctions are to come
can he be clear with us then what is the
trigger
i i think it's inevitable that there
will be uh more sanctions to come
because i'm afraid i think it inevitable
uh that uh vladimir putin is going to
continue uh with his flagrant violation
of international or what we're doing
today
is the first barrage uh that we're
orchestrating uh in concert with uh our
friends and partners uh keeping keeping
something in reserve keeping something
in reserve because uh there must still
be the possibility that we can avert
a hideous outbreak of bloodshed in
ukraine isabel
thank you mr speaker the prime
minister's right to say that ukraine has
been evaded invaded by russia
i think both sides of the house were
expecting
stronger sanctions to be announced today
and i think maybe that's what the
government wanted to do but the prime
minister said he had to move in lockstep
with our other allies was there
resistance from other allies to bring in
full sanctions today
different countries have different uh
priorities and
considerations it's considerably easier
for us to impose economic sanctions it's
it's difficult for some other countries
to impose sanctions on to block
hydrocarbons but i'm very pleased by the
progress that the german government has
made
thank you mr speaker this is a day of
infamy in russian history but the truth
is that we're here today because our
strategy of deterrence has failed
president putin has built an arsenal of
kleptocracy he perverts history for his
pretext and he perverts science for his
weapons but the risk is that today's
slap on the wrist will not deter
anything further it's been 2014 since we
proposed sanctions for economic crimes
apart from the magnitsky sanctions the
sanctions against the oligarchs have
been on the american list since 2018.
missing from the list was vtb veb alpha
spear bank
the prime minister's got to recognize
that pulling our punches does not work
with president putin we need to punch
harder and if we're not prepared to send
bombers we should at least take on the
bankers
mr speaker we certainly are taking on uh
the bankers who are hitting uh we're
hitting russia's financial interests and
we will continue uh to hit them harder
title fabricant
speaker
85 years ago
a predecessor of the prime minister
talked about a quarrel in a far away
country
between people of whom we know nothing
doesn't the
concordance
between both sides of the house today
demonstrate
that this is not the case when it comes
to ukraine
my honourable friend is is so right and
i think everybody who uh
knows people in the ukrainian community
uh in in britain which is so large so uh
so active uh makes such a fantastic
contribution to to our life uh feels a
huge amount of sympathy for the people
of ukraine today uh this is a country
that uh that we have uh familiarity that
we understand it's a country that is a
democracy and that shares our values and
that's that's what's at stake today jim
shaw
can i thank the prime minister for
for his statement and what he has said
today as we've woken up to disturbing
news of russian aggression does the
prime minister not agree that economic
sanctions while it's welcome will not be
enough and as such is the prime minister
prepared to underline the steps that
have been taken with nato allies to
assess the situation and stress that
membership in nato is not a previous hit
for us and the united kingdom of great
britain and northern for supporting
democracy in whatever way is deemed
necessary
he's quite right that uh it is up to the
people of of ukraine to decide uh what
alliance they aspire to join and uh
nato's
nato's open door policy should remain uh
absolutely environment
uh thank you uh mr speaker i strongly
support the approach of the government
and unlike my writing of gwenville
litchfield said it is not a far away
country which we know nothing can i just
ask my wife friend what assessment have
the government made of the impacts from
the war on energy prices of oil prices
and the subsequent impacts on people on
people at home and what measures can the
government mitigate
uh are those uh factors which are as we
know the war is likely to increase the
cost of living for ordinary folk across
the country
he he's quite right that one of the
risks of uh of putin's uh venture is
that there could be a spike in uh in in
gas prices and oil prices uh mr speaker
and the government will do everything we
can to mitigate and to help the people
of this country but it's one of the
reasons why
the whole of western europe has got to
end their dependence on on russian oil
and gas
[Applause]
thank you mr speaker well the prime
minister they're outlining to the house
of commons what steps the uk is going to
take against russia following uh their
movements around the borders of ukraine
today the prime minister must brace
ourselves for the next stage of putin's
plan that we've explored every arena and
given putin every opportunity to pursue
his
aims via democracy that there is no
doubt that the deployment of russian
forces in ukraine amounts to renew
renewed invasion and if the worst
happens then a european nation will
become the target of a full-scale war of
aggression waged without a shred of
justification
they are he'll say that we're willing to
send more british forces to help protect
allies if nato makes a request and the
first tranche of what they are doing is
putting sanctions on five russian banks
and also three
individuals uh and and his words
welcomed by the opposition leader kier
stama uh also adding that we must be
prepared to go further former prime
minister theresa may interestingly
saying that this is a defense of
democracy itself
well a little earlier we heard from
vladimir putin as he met the azerbaijani
president in the decision yesterday to
acknowledge sovereignty of two republics
in donbass
and we've
foresaw
uh turbulations
on this matter
and talks that
russia is trying to recreate empire and
this is not true at all
um
after the fall of the soviet union uh
russia has recognized all new uh
realities of
of the borders and we as you know have
been working very productively with all
other countries we are acting in exactly
the same way
with all our neighbors unfortunately
with ukraine
this is a different situation because
the territory of ukraine is being used
for threats against russian federation
currently
well joining me now is the ukrainian mp
and the first deputy chairman of the
foreign affairs committee gregory
nemeria um just getting your reaction to
what president putin just said that the
territory of ukraine is being used to
threaten russia what would you say to
that
yeah i
definitely cannot agree this president
putin and also yesterday when i listened
to his address to the russian people my
summary would be that in this address
his point major point was that ukraine
has no right for its independence
sovereignty and it's not the country so
that's why
i uh
do not agree was putin is saying will be
saying because what has happened
yesterday and is happening today
it's a clear act of aggression it's a
death factor annexation of the part of
eastern ukraine donbass and my hometown
is donetsk by the way the twin city of
chateau so now if you take crimea and
pato donbass it's more than 44 000
square kilometers that russia illegally
annexed and occupied so that's a
territory uh larger than the territory
of some european countries like
switzerland or netherlands or denmark
he says that he is acknowledging the
sovereignty of the donbass region
so uh donbass region is integral part of
ukraine
so he cannot acknowledge the sovereignty
of part of ukraine acknowledging the
so-called sovereignty of the so-called
donetsk people's republican look guns
people uh republics he basically
proclaiming that he is going to continue
to dismember ukraine and partition it
how worried are you that this will will
expand beyond even donetsk and luhansk
further into ukraine
there is real threat direct and clear
threat because uh one should also be
reminded that back in 2014 the so-called
republic's
proclaimed that their territories uh
within the former administrative borders
uh of the uh uh at the time of the
soviet union and uh so they have an
aspiration also to increase their
territory at the expense of the uh
cities uh and the territories that are
currently under control of ukraine
including the uh port city of mariupol
and the azov sea major cities of
kramatorsk and some others so this is a
clearly naked act of aggression in the
international arm conflict where russia
is an aggressor and by the way i don't
agree with naming what is happening in
in ukraine now uh ukraine crisis it is
not the ukraine crisis it is crisis of
european security and it is